hello reject nation it's greg alba here
it's Andrew here Andrew Gordon from the
movie source channel with us today we
saw just asleep together and he plays
the game injustice I'm like Andrew this
video is gonna be perfectly suited for
our tastes I love Justice League you can
go to Andrews channel to find out what
he thinks about Justice League he's like
I enjoyed it it was definitely a lot
better than I thought it was gonna be
the Justice League comes to injustice
apparently I did not hear about that I
didn't either that sounds awesome
guys sent to us over on our Facebook
page so I was like alright cool let's
check this out I'm pretty sure it's like
when they do I remember they had like
Suicide Squad members come on so I'm
sure it's the movie characters oh yeah I
think I'm most excited to see like
surfer Aquaman vs the injustice I'm
[Music]
excited to see fat flick oh yeah oh how
about Superman I want upper-lip Superman
the problem
[Music]
oh it's the actual movie footage [ __ ]
actually that's too real oh there it is
yeah
they are happy
[Music]
[Music]
yeah oh
whoa
I'm looking for oh man the owner looked
a little off is Jason Momoa do we even
see gal gadot this Wonder Woman
and I we just sell regulate I think it
was just the one woman from the video
game yeah I think that was unlisted just
it was happening kind of fast though I
don't know what was confusing me was
they kept intercutting with actual
footages yes I was the actual footage to
serve CGI though I'm like where's this
game player is this right yeah is the
actual thing but no the two flashes
squaring off the flash suit looks better
in the injustice game than it doesn't
seeing them both interact and then when
you see him throw like Captain cold and
into Captain Cold like that was really
cool and I thought the batfleck sued the
armored one yeah that looks like Batman
Arkham City that one looks the sickest
to me yeah I'm a little biased well he
was like between BBS and Justice League
Batman wears like three different suits
right because he changed his suit he's
got the first suit he wears in VBS when
he fights Superman the beginning of
suicide suit Suicide Squad
oh yeah and Suicide Squad he's wearing
the same suit from BBS and then when we
get to Justice League he's still wearing
that same suit the one that's kind of
like this from the throughout the
beginning and then in the final
climactic battle that's when he switches
switches here that said yes the buffer
suit I don't know why I was getting
flashbacks a little visual imagery why I
said George Clooney's second suit that
he wears in vain yeah and the silver and
all that but this one obviously is way
sicker with the goggles and all that but
I'm also wondering you know how in the
cutscenes Ivan Justice before you fight
they always have like some quippy thing
that they say to each other before they
square off I wonder if they got the
actual actors to come on board deliver a
few lines I don't know if I see that
happening that'd be for today I'll see
ya for DLC I don't know if I see that'd
be really cool though I know they were
more selling the trailer but we did see
that that clip of cyborg saying you
should probably move so I don't know if
maybe they're gonna interact lines from
a movie they'll take the deleted scenes
yeah it'd be down for that if they can
somehow interact their voices in there
that play I mean whatever makes it feel
more real but I will admit it's good at
first it will sound it would be a little
weird if you hear some and a voice actor
trying to imitate Ben Affleck doing that
yeah well I mean he does have the voice
changer that's true or a bum or Aquaman
or someone like that or even gal gadot
yeah I wish you saw Henry Cavill
Superman I wonder if you but I mean when
it comes out obviously I'm just gonna be
looking at alright guys well I don't
know if the DLCs already been added in
I'm assuming it has been probably I
haven't been playing too much and just
thanks to you since we did that freaking
last of us video I've been like so
locked back again I'll get back on
injustice and take a look at that I know
they added the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles how is that looks oh yeah I
definitely got to get on it cuz I have
not been playing too much it's like some
of the best DLCs on this game yeah in
the graphics I haven't even got a play
as Hellboy yet alright guys well thanks
for whomever sent that over to us forgot
a name check that before the video but
thank you you can subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
bell make sure to follow Andrew at the
movie source channel there's a lot of
great movie reviews over there's a lot
of also cool speculation and theories as
well those are actually some of us
better performing ones and there's a
reason why go check it out it's
fantastic channel the best channel it's
a fantastic airtime Trump ruin the work
fantastic for everyone